[Musik]
der wolf frisst die brandenburger schafe
der problembär verschreckt bayerische
wanderer
doch der wahre feind lauert tief im
boden wie crossair wales die feldmaus
frisst den thüringer bauern die ernte
weg ich begebe mich ins krisengebiet
treffe den bauern hönighaus beseitigten
den naturschützer so ich habe mit nichts
am hut und den landwirtschaftsminister
ich habe in viele augen von feldmäusen
geguckt und alle sind freund und feind
der maus zugleich
was hat die feldmaus ihnen getan die
feldmaus ist individuell ein ebenso
possierliches wie liebenswert ist hier
das jedoch in großer menge auftreten
dazu führt dass wir uns die frage
stellen müssen brot auf den teller oder
feldmaus aufenthalt hat die süße
feldmaus überhaupt ein recht zu leben
und wo sind die viecher ist das nun mal
aus auch das ist ne maus auch ist das
normal aus das wahnsinnig ist das ne
maus sicherheit und das ja das ist alles
mäuse ja also ich war gerade beim land
wirtschaftsminister von thüringen
professor doktor hoff und der hat gesagt
die muss man alle töten er hat folgendes
gesagt also man man hat diese giftköder
dann macht man eben diese mäuse löcher
rein macht man die mäuse ja zu und dann
ist ja alles dufte weil dann sterben die
mäuse drin und drum herum passiert ja
gar nicht das war genial
ja aber das wissen die meisten nicht
wenn ich jetzt das auf fünf bis zehn
euro pro quadratmeter habe dann ist der
bauer ist ja unterwegs also dann ist
sowieso alles zu spät da gar keine zeit
da kann sie nicht in der bäuerin kümmern
nicht um die kühe nicht um gar nichts
mehr stimmt das verhindert die feldmaus
wirklich sex in der bäuerlichen ehe das
habe ich mich dann doch nicht zu fragen
getraut lieber irgendwas mit politik die
politik sei schneller werden das halte
ich für eher unrealistisch was ist ihre
forderung an die mäuse dass ich von
meinem akku kann halten ok und die bauen
die vorgärten da nachbarn gehen
da machen dann erste aufschrei nämlich
relativ groß und dann ist das auch
schnell in der politik und dann zeigt
mir der bauer wie man mit der mäuse
flinte mäuse erlebt körner rein
zugetreten und im aus tod musst du ganz
einfach tun die man mit der maus tut
schon weh okay die maus muss sterben
aber dann doch lieber durch einen
natürlichen feind
man könnte zum beispiel umbrechen das
wird teilweise auch gemacht dass man mit
einem flug reingeht und dann hätte man
zb die ganze struktur dass man einmal
oben gedreht im ausmustern will doch
einfach mit butter den muss an der
oberfläche kommt der greifvogel umkreist
dass ich das ja auch zynisch oder ja
aber das ist der natürliche ablagen ja
ja aber es auch schöne stellt natürlich
ablaufen
nein das ist die maus ist ja dafür
dauert das er vom greifvogel gefressen
wird oder vom mauswiesel ich die ist ja
nicht dazu dort den bauern zu haben
das feldmaus problem ist zwar menschen
gemacht aber jetzt soll wieder der
greifvogel die drecksarbeit machen na
super
und wo ist er überhaupt der vogel der
sitzt für den greifvogel steht jetzt der
greifvogel kommen wie locken
da kommen wir ganz alleine das sieht ja
und das ich glaub ja wo ist im moment
nicht da wie geht es dem vogel ruf
wollen wir gedacht ehrlich gesagt zum
glück ist kein greifvogel aufgetaucht
frist der nämlich eine vergiftete maus
ist er ebenfalls mausetot und dem
feldhamster jetzt genauso wenn er gift
körnerfutter das muss doch irgendwie
anders gehen was soll der bauer jetzt
tun wie wir es mit gift das man nicht
nachweisen kann
[Musik]
sie haben nicht zum lachen gebracht
gott segne sie okay das ist vielleicht
so hart machen wir es doch wie im
mittelalter und führen sie an einem
besseren ort aufzuteilen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja it service provider sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe ja probieren sie doch mal den
kanal der heute show auf youtube zu
abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung